mr speaker the evidence of the scale and
the severity of the human rights
violations being perpetrated
in xinjiang against the uyghur muslims
is now far reaching
and it paints a truly harrowing picture
violations include the extrajudicial
detention of over a million weakers and
other minorities
in political re-education camps
extensive and invasive surveillance
targeting minorities
systematic restrictions on uyghur
culture education
and indeed the practice of islam and the
widespread use
of forced labour
the nature and conditions of detention
violate basic standards of human rights
and that the worst
amount to torture and inhumane and
degrading treatment
alongside widespread reports of the
forced sterilization of we go uh women
internment camps arbitrary detention
political re-education forced labour
torture and forced sterilization
all on an industrial scale
it is truly horrific barbarism we had
hoped
lost to another era being practiced
today as we speak
in one of the leading members of the
international community
and today i can announce a range of new
measures
to send a clear message that these
violations of human rights
are unacceptable and at the same time to
safeguard
uk businesses and public bodies from any
involvement or links
with them i've been working
closely with my right-hand friends the
home secretary the secretary of state
for
international trade and the chancellor
of the duchy of lancaster
and our aim put simply is that no
company that profits from forced labour
in xinyang
can do business in the uk and no uk
business is involved in their supply
chains
let me set out the four new steps we are
now taking
first today the fcdo and dit have issued
new robust and detailed guidance to uk
businesses
on these specific risks faced by
companies with links to xinjiang
and underlining the challenges of
conducting effective due diligence there
a minister-led campaign of business
engagement will reinforce
the need for uk businesses to take
concerted action to address that
particular
and specific risk second mr speaker we
are strengthening the operation
of the modern slavery act the home
office will introduce fines for
businesses
that do not comply with their
transparency obligations
and the home secretary will introduce
the necessary legislation setting out
the level of those fines
as soon as parliamentary time allows
third we announced last september that
the
transparency requirements that apply to
uk businesses
under the modern slavery act will be
extended to the public sector
so the scdo will now work with the
cabinet office to provide
guidance and support to uk government
bodies to exclude suppliers
where there is sufficient evidence of
human rights violations in
any of their supply chains